hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
categories chapter eight contains a
lengthy discussion of the category of
quality and Aristotle distinguishes four
main types of quality the third type
that he talks about really seems to be
two different but overlapping things and
I think that this is probably one of the
discussions that certainly in that
chapter is the most difficult for the
average or the first-time reader coming
to the work perhaps it's one of the more
difficult than the work itself so we're
gonna try to make some sense of it for
you
Aristotle here talks about two things
that are lexically connected with each
other
and are a little bit difficult to
translate so he talks about passive
qualities right pathetic I play Oh
today's point Toyota takes as the plural
four qualities and this word pathetic I
you know if you see pathos or pathetic
there you're on the right track it's
coming from the verb pas skåne which
means to suffer it's the sort of
correlative of poi n which means to do
and you notice that you know towards the
end of the list of the categories we
have
doing and you know being done to or
suffering or passion sometimes
translation and passion and this is
connected with with that certainly
lexically and I think even conceptually
then he talks about what we're often
translating as affections here path a
pathos is the singular of that and a
pathos can mean anything that we suffer
but it's also a term that's used for the
emotions because in part the Aristotle
and the other you know Greek writers on
this viewed emotions as something that
you know are sort of imposed upon us
either by your outside you know things
impinging from the firm from our
environment events we also contribute
something to it but but they kind of
grip us and and we don't necessarily
choose them as such the way we seem to
do with her actions now how are these
connected with each other we're gonna
have to disentangle them a bit aerosol
starts out by talking about the the
passive qualities and he very helpfully
begins with several examples sweetness
and bitterness right coldness and warmth
whiteness and blackness those are is go
to colors he's going to discuss some
other colors a little bit later in the
chapter so the things that have these
the things that that in which these
things are like the whiteness or
blackness right or blueness the the tie
is blue because it has blueness in it
remember all that talked about in a
subject predicated of a subject right
it's a blue tie it has a certain quality
as that it could be a red tie it could
be a green time being a tie being blue
you know is not essential to being a tie
but but it's you know the way this tie
is right blue shirt as well so
all of them are called of that quality
we get to about blue things or lukewarm
things or sour things right and that
sourness or blueness or lukewarm
entities apoyo tastes and now Aristotle
wants to make clear that and I think
this probably only holds for most cases
he talks about it in rather sweeping
terms that it's not something that's
changed in the thing per se
for example honey is sweet right but
it's not as if the sweetness in the
honey changes the honey somehow honey
just is sweet this tie simply is blue
now perhaps it started out as you know
in this case no I don't I don't think
that it started out it's just a white
tie but then it was dipped in blue dye
or something like that but Aristotle
says that these these these qualities
are not making the thing itself that
they reside in passive why do we call
them passive then why do we use this
term well because they're actually not
passive they can produce and the word
that he uses there's poison to do to
produce to create they can create a
sensation or affection apollo's in
something else the perceiver who
perceives them so for example taste the
sense of taste which is coming from the
tongue is affected by sweetness so you
taste some sugar or some honey or some
you know malted barley or anything else
that that has sweetness to it and you
your tongue takes that in and you go oh
nuts that's sweet right and we say the
sweetness is there in the thing but it's
actually there on your tongue or in your
your sensation right so the sweetness is
in part at least in the pathos that you
are experiencing so these qualities are
you know is it's kind of misnomer to
call them
Takai toyota case when we might actually
you know stretch it out a little bit
further and say that they are instead of
just being passive qualities qualities
productive of a passion or affection
within somebody else so those are some
typical examples that he uses then he
passes on to start talking about path a
which we're translating as affections
and he does this by way of talking about
color at first and so there's a little
bit of shifting going on here so we're
not just thinking about the color like
the color of the tie or the color that
my skin normally is we're thinking about
the color that we might actually change
to give in certain circumstances and one
of those circumstances that he talks
about is when we feel affections when we
are affected in a certain way for
example when we feel an emotion so you
know we can talk about the physiological
effects of fear for example of you know
the limbs trembling and he's talking
about color so he's thinking about the
blood you know receding away from the
face and and really into the core which
makes us get peeler now it's interesting
too when when you look at ancient Greek
writings on this sometimes they don't
talk about turning white for example the
way that somebody with a pink skin tone
people with olive skin tones when the
the you know the the blood is moving
away it's a slightly different color
combination so Homer for example will
talk about turning yellow right because
the the the stuff is going away shame
embarrassment is another way of putting
it when we feel embarrassed we turn red
right and Aristotle talks about this as
here we go
he says there's numerous changes of
color that clearly arise from effect
when men are ashamed then they blush
when alarmed they turned pale so much is
this really the case that I think when a
man is by nature disposed towards shame
or alarm is arising from a certain
concommittant of bodily elements in him
we may not unfairly conclude that he
takes on the corresponding color for the
state of the bodily elements may very
well result from his physical
organization and thus alike color may
also arise in the process of nature so
Aristotle points out that sometimes
these things that we see coming from you
know the fear response or the shame
response can also stem from natural
conditions what would be examples of
this
Aristotle brings up sunburn as an
example of something that Redden's
the skin interesting example he also
talks about disease and there we might
have in mind something like anemia when
people turn pale because of you know
problems with the blood we could also
think about jaundice which which makes a
person their skin and even sometimes the
eyes turn turn yellow because of what's
going on in the liver and so there's
there's plenty of things along those
lines that would be going on now
Aristotle wants to say look in a lot of
cases what we're talking about are not
actually qualities as such because they
don't remain within the person very long
so he has something a little bit
stronger in mind than just quality per
se when he's when he's talking about
these affections sources conditions
arising from causes soon rendered
inoperative if not entirely removed will
be known as affections as pave not
qualities seeing that no one has called
such and such on account of these
conditions so a person who blushes from
shame is not regarded as naturally ruddy
nor he who becomes pale from fear as
having a pallid complexion instead we
say so-and-so was affected such states
are affections not qualities so perhaps
in cases like that Aristotle would say
what we're
is actually a different category the
category of passion or suffering however
you want to put it not the category of
quality as as such he goes on to say
that this also holds for things within
the soul or the mind the sukkah
and he says when a person has a temper
from birth and its source is in certain
affections not easy to change or remove
then we give it the name of a quality or
ask ability right when a person just
happens to lose their temper on the spot
we say that they're angry but we don't
say that their ear askable we don't call
them the Rask ability era is is the
Latin word it in Greek or gay is anger
also thumos and a few other words and/or
delos is the name of somebody who is a
rascal somebody who's prone to anger and
so Aristotle says you know madness ear
ask ability other things like that our
case is in point it's on account of such
things we call a person mad or irascible
and so he also talks about for you know
in other examples distractions of mind
which can arise from certain things
coming together in a person and these
can seem to be either enduring or very
hard to remove so those would be called
qualities as well
passive qualities so passive qualities
here is really being used to mean
two different but connected things one
is what can produce a sensation in a
subject the other is something some sort
of you know feeling or sensation within
a subject that then can be shown in
outward signs perhaps of the color of
the face so you want to keep those those
separate Aristotle is moving from one to
the other fairly rapidly
you want to try to separate those out a
little bit and keep them distinct so
that you don't get mixed up and you can
ask when when we're talking about some
sort of quality is
this type or is it this type here